the 61st annual Academy Awards is being
brought to you by the heartbeat of
America today Chevrolet AT&T the right
choice the good time great taste of
McDonald's and JCPenney you're looking
smarter than ever at JCPenney
ladies and gentlemen Billy Crystal
thank you this is an amazing thing to
walk out and see all these great stars
this is almost like onto a lake again is
it good
I have been asked to present a package
of clips about tap-dancing in the movies
now this is something I am a fan of but
I know very little about growing up in
New York I was a big fan of movie
musicals never quite understood them no
I mean really West Side Story the first
musical I saw I grew up in New York I
never saw tough guys walk down the
street like that riff me to the gym at
9:00 don't wear that I never saw that
but if they had asked me about my
favorite movies I would talk about the
10 commandments which was on the other
night it's a great movie it's a lesson
for all actors be very careful if you do
a biblical film certain actors can do a
Charlton Heston was phenomenal in it
Edward G Robinson a great actor I didn't
quite get it where's your Messiah now
where's your Moses now G now let my
people go now fight get it
what Yul Brynner was Yul Brynner was
great in that movie Yul Brynner could do
anything but did you know that mr.
Berner was the original Babe Ruth in the
Babe Ruth story which later was played
by William Bendix true shot three days
didn't quite work hey babe gonna hit a
home run today I'm going to try
boy after you the Chicago Cubs that got
me nuts but there's a keep is a boy you
sick boy Brooklyn I promised him I did a
single a double triple etcetera etcetera
cetera was good they didn't ask me about
that I'm a hit with a band they didn't
ask me about that you guys all went at
the same place oh I didn't ask me about
the new movies coming out this summer
the great sequel to the classic Of Mice
and Men starring George Bush and Dan
Quayle won't tell me about the country's
George tell me about the Contras and ask
about that
there's a new breeze blowing no I want
to know anyway I went too far they asked
me to look at this clip about tap
dancing and I looked at it he's a
tremendous artist but as I was looking
at and I thought that I could do that
easily and I came up with a way that you
can do this too now please don't try
this at home I am a professional here's
how you can learn how to tap at home all
you need is a hand mic a little
eucalyptus cough drop and watching you
can tap like any of these great artists
you're about to see all right
so would you please welcome two great
artists wonderful my back today with the
other one I've been on occasion ladies
and gentlemen Gregory Hines and Sammy
Davis jr.
you